I was never interested in growing on
Instagram but I use it as kind of like a
resume I'm in the process of promoting a
book and some of the best videos that I
found so far on YouTube on how to
promote a book are from Evan Carmichaels
if you want to sell a book then you need
to grow your following it can't just be
a resume because you want people to buy
your book there's nothing wrong with
just having Instagram as a resume cool
that can definitely work but like what
are your goals so my goal is to sell the
book cool now we need to have an
audience when you're thinking about
something like a book or product or a
course launch or any of these things
that we're trying to sell as experts
there's always your own audience and
then there's other people's audiences
your own audience is the best long-term
most sustainable thing that you can use
and build hopefully there's not just one
book inside Jose Gonzalez there's more
books coming up and so the more you have
an audience the more you can promote
your book
for future ones that come out so now we
need to start building an audience and
so what is your message what is your
content that's not going to happen like
instantly right away but we need to
start gearing our minds towards sharing
your message with people so that they
love you and they end up wanting to
support you and also support themselves
by picking up your books Etc next more
short term for your own following you
could DM everybody on Instagram with a
video asking for support
so if I really really really really
really really really really needed to
sell Bill to Surf like if that was my
top priority I would go through whoever
followed me now we've got you know a
quarter million people on Instagram but
if it was 2 000 or 100 I would I would
video DM everybody
to say hey Faith thank you so much for
following me I want to let you know I've
got a new book it's called built to
serve I love your support if if I
continue link to check it out
hey lady Lexi thank you so much for
following me like one by one
hand-to-hand combat going off to tell
people what you've got and asking for
their support
and so the bigger audience you have
they're easier that is to do it's not
you know there's only so many you can do
in a day right it's like I couldn't do
that for everybody who follows me but if
I if I was getting started and I wanted
to get my book out or I was launching my
course or whatever that's what I would
do that's why Instagram becomes
important
um we were watching a video this morning
from the CEO of Instagram talking about
Instagram's growth is in direct
messaging and reels
it's not about the pictures it's about
the a lot of a lot happens in the direct
messaging and then in the reels for
Content so use it's my favorite platform
for direct messaging every morning I'm
walking outside and I'm sending videos
to people thanking them for different
things
so that's what I would do as a starting
point with your audience and but it
changes the mindset now it's not just
a resume
that whether it's Instagram or Tick Tock
or YouTube now you you need to build an
audience if you want to sell your books
and anything else
um and then phase two would be also who
else can you
who has an audience that might be
willing to put you on
so one of the biggest things authors
always do when they come up with a new
book is they go in other people's shows
whether it's an Instagram live whether
it's YouTube whether it's tick tock like
wherever they have their audience you
want to try to be a part of it and
hopefully you gain a little bit of
following from them as well so that's
not a sustainable as building up your
own following but whenever you're in
launch mode that's always the two things
like what do I have for my own audience
and and who's who are the other people
whose audience I can tap into to promote
my book
awesome thank you Max good to see you
again cool man I love it we got Tanya in
the house what do we got Tanya
yes hi Evan uh so my question is in
regards of when you are using different
platforms like
um you have your followers all spread
out how is there any way is there any
strategy I don't know to kind of like
direct them to the one that you want to
grow like when I have my personal
account and I have my business account
so in business we have Facebook we have
Tick Tock we have Instagram
uh yes and and we are creating YouTube
after I started moving movement makers I
realized that you know we were missing
that one
yeah
then we should have had before but yeah
so we are developing that one so my idea
is kind of like mirror what you're doing
and make uh give uh give more importance
to YouTube and then Tick Tock with which
I think is great it's a great platform I
I I haven't paid attention as much but I
like it especially for my audience and
then Instagram but I have
you know I have audience like spread out
is there any way together
I would say
it's not a great strategy to bring it
all together
so you want to meet people where they're
at
some people love Tick Tock and they just
want to stay on Tick Tock so don't try
to get them to Instagram like Instagram
I don't want to use Instagram
some people love YouTube so meet them on
YouTube and if you want to have a big
message then like someone like for me I
want to solve the world's biggest
problem so I got to be I got to be where
the most people are
if you have a if you have a niche
business and it only caters to certain
people then you want to be where those
people are like Tony he was on Facebook
right it's like to say I need everybody
to get over to Facebook
right to do that is crazy because people
are they don't want to use Facebook
anymore
so you meet people where they're at and
help them with what they need help with
and so that might mean having maybe you
can't be on every platform yourself
right now that's okay like you have to
pick YouTube and and one other cool
um but I wouldn't the only thing I would
try to do is capture their email address
so that you have a way to communicate
with them
but I wouldn't try to consolidate them
because a lot of my audience doesn't
want to meet me on Tick Tock or
Instagram and so and and when you do it
doesn't convert very well like when
people come from my take my Instagram to
YouTube they don't watch the videos for
very long
so I actually want them to stay on
Instagram or on Tick Tock or on YouTube
like stay on the platform unless it's
converting to a sale
they're gonna hire you for something or
convert into an email address where
they're gonna
give you their email in exchange for
some bonus that you're going to give
them
okay great beautiful
all right we got we got two minutes
Maria what do we got let's do it
I don't know it might be too much but
we'll do what we can so I I have I keep
grappling with this for years I have a
niche problem where I have two separate
websites
and I get clients from both and I I so
I'm sort of since I joined movement
makers I I body confidence Solutions and
I know that the underlying reason that I
help people have sustainable change is I
deal with trauma I deal with stress I
deal with all the stuff that keeps them
you know just recycling back into Old
behaviors and so I have another website
modern stress Solutions which I still
like I was just invited
um on Monday so mayor's um is uh mental
health awareness month and I was invited
to do a presentation to 270 construction
workers because the suicide is the
highest industry of suicide
it was so gratifying but the point is
that I like I love doing that kind of
stuff around Stress Management around
so like people that look at
bodyconfidence solutions they think well
she's a health coach
I on my I mean I talk about
transformation from the inside out and I
go deeper in my videos about yeah living
in your body and having a more better
connection with your body but that
includes releasing stress trauma
so it feels a lot to have two separate
websites I do two separate newsletters
every week sort of crazy
and I don't know if there's a way to I
mean they they are both connected and
they and you know my stories that I
healed from multiple Eating Disorders
but the stress Solutions is really the
how
you know
so um I don't know I guess my question
is
um
do I like I even notice when I do my
lives on Instagram and people there's
some people that like they really want
to learn some of these techniques even
if they're not struggling with their
wage
so do I I mean do I just keep my Niche
like with you know Health around weight
food and or broaden it I mean I get more
gratification out of
well I guess I'll add all of all of it
as long as I'm serving and helping
people to uncover the stuff that's
keeping them stuck that's the piece for
me whether it's weight addictive
behavior or
you know depression or any of that
so I think I think it's something a lot
of entrepreneurs struggle with to The
Branding and how many brands do I have
and how many websites and how many
accounts it it it is very taxing to have
multiple accounts and multiple domain
names and multiple emails and multiple
Instagrams and multiple tick tocks it
can be very very demanding it's usually
not worth it
um so you have a couple scenarios one
you you leave one that's just more on
autopilot that's there that you're not
actively we're not taking it down but
we're not really doing much with it
because if something comes in cool but
it's not really where we're putting our
Focus or two you combine them into one
and and the one brand is not
not a brand name like body confidence
Solutions the combination is Maria
lipuma
and so everything that I do I'm a
different person to different people for
some people I'm the believe guy for some
people I'm the YouTube guy for some
people I'm the you know the author for
some people I'm the salsa dancer you
know I'll go salsa dancing you know
brought up my studio but some people
don't even know what my business is I'm
just a guy who owns this also studio and
so it leads to different conversations
but inside everything is still believe
for me you're teaching believe through
the books through the content through
the YouTube channel through salsa
dancing through everything is all that's
the Common Thread so that for me is
easier and my my brands have always been
a reflection of me when I first started
my website I did Evan carmichael.com as
a
as just as a landing spot like no real
thought behind it and then as SEO became
a thing I wish I call it like why didn't
I call it Small Business Solutions or
something like why didn't you put some
keywords in there and then I realized no
it's actually better
that I kept it off my name because my
name could be whatever I want my name to
be
and so you might find yourself in
another field in a couple years that
still relates to stress and anxiety and
how to overcome those but maybe it's
something completely different that you
realize it's still the same
um so I'm I'm in general it's easier
to build it off of a personal brand as
opposed to a company name that kind of
locks you into a niche so those are your
your three options like one you run all
you run both together and kind of will
always feel stretched between the two
maybe bring on team and help but uh you
probably won't do either of them really
well
option two is you take one and you
really commit to it and the other one
you just leave on autopilot and when
stuff happens stuff happens cool but
like this is what I'm going to be known
for or option three is you just build
your personal brand and wherever Maria
wants to go that's what Maria ends up
creating and it gives you a lot more
flexibility to do the next thing so I
thought it was the worst decision like
if you go back and ask me when I was 23
years old I thought building it off of
Evan Carmichael first off sounds super
egotistical and also was like this is
the stupidest thing I could have made
because nobody knows who I am but if I
called it Small Business Solutions or
something it makes more sense but that
ended up being the most genius thing
that I could have done
um and people will connect with your
brand your personal face and your
message more than a company logo
this week's topic was Maria who picked
Niche picking one and staying with it
how to narrow when in it to include
another Niche uh well since we have
Maria here why don't we uh Workshop this
a little bit what what's uh what's on
your mind where's this coming from thank
you Evan and thank you so much for I'm
just blown away with your generosity
with the challenge and
anyway uh thank you so I've been you
know I've I've shifted my Niche a few
times over the years because I I address
women that struggle in their
relationship to food Weight and Body
Image but it's typically the tip of the
iceberg and usually the deeper blocks
the emotional blocks sometimes trauma
sometimes Stress Management sometimes
that's where you have to go to have
long-term healing and so
I'm you know I I Market to that
particular population but I work with
people that struggle with anxiety and
because that's usually the next layer
right people are medicating with food
it's a lot of times they're medicating
their anxiety or their and one of the
things I just watched your interview
with Melanie because I I am a emotional
Freedom techniques Master practitioner
and that's one of the techniques that I
actually use to one of them that help
people to have more peace in their with
their emotional body so my question is
do I just stick to this Niche or do I
broaden it like when is like when is the
time to do that or do I just keep doing
what I'm doing and because for instance
I'll work with someone and then she'll
send me her husband because her husband
has anxiety issues you know so
I don't know if that's clear no no I
mean thank you great and think everybody
kind of struggles with forms of this at
some point when they're figuring out
their content Their audience
um what you need to think about is who
so in in looking at your titles for the
movement makers challenge that we're
going through right now all your titles
came back to helping women right like
everything said women which is fine so
you know I love I'll believe in anybody
I like if somebody if you sent me
somebody who or I'm talking to somebody
who's an employee and never wants to be
an entrepreneur I'll still have the
conversation and help them it's just not
really what I want to be doing you know
it's like it's not at the core of what I
love the most because that's I love
serving entrepreneurs more so it doesn't
mean that hey because you're a man I'm
not going to talk to you you know but if
you love serving women then you focus on
that audience first
inside of that
you get the pick is it really mental
health stuff that you love about a love
caring about is it really the weight
loss Journey because that leads to the
mental health stuff you know like who do
you love helping the most like if you
had to pick we all love serving we all
love helping if we see somebody fall on
the street we're gonna go and and help
them up I hope readers built to serve
readers okay you see somebody follow the
street you go help them up
but that's not like what we want to you
know be spending our days doing it's
just we see somebody in need and we do
what we can to support
um you know right now uh the whole thing
in Ukraine like my main video editor her
she's Ukrainian and she left three uh no
she left like five years ago from
Ukraine to go to Montenegro and
um
because of war and potential war and all
that so she's safe but her family is in
the Ukraine and we've been spending the
past time kind of figuring out hey how
how can I help I mean I I'm in Canada
like do they need money like is your
family safe can they fly out of the
country can they get somewhere where
they need to go you know I I don't speak
the language or have any connections but
uh if if money is a problem to get
people what they need like let me know
um and you know I'm helping with that
but it's not what I want I my mission
isn't going into war-torn countries and
helping people escape but you know right
so we do what we can to serve the people
who are around us but like who do you
who would you spend or love spending the
most time with it's like just absolutely
feeds your soul who are they and what
are they struggling with in the
challenge of the movement makers
the thing we're going through right now
is to try to get it more specific so
that when you're making the content it's
not just how to fix your anxiety
which is great but specific to like who
are the people who love helping them out
so in that context who do you who would
you love helping like the most the most
the most yeah so
my word is care and my mission really is
I feel passionate about this is to to
help women to get beyond the struggles
that undermine them so that they can
stand in their life and and be their
best self and and serve in the way that
they've been called to serve because I
feel like the advancement of women and
you know we in this country we have we
have more freedom than many women on the
planet and yet we're emotionally
oppressed by Body Image issues and
weight issues and and all that chips
away at us being our best self so I feel
passionate about that and also my story
is about that I've come from multiple
eating disorders and I've worked in so I
you know I'm on the other side of that
now and I feel like my purpose is my
passion I mean my pain has been my
passion
so yes that's that gives me greatest
pleasure when I have clients that are
you know getting beyond the dieting
stuff and and really looking you know
living a Freer life and they're and
they're finding their purpose beyond
that and not teaching their little
daughters to be over concerned about
diet and weight but that these girls can
come into the world with more empowered
about
who they are as a person not necessarily
how they look so I mean that's part of
it yeah I mean I love I love that you so
you have your Niche women which is
awesome now now that's like
half of the population so we've narrowed
it down a little bit but
getting a little more specific to then
the next step and the problem that
they're facing is helpful because if you
only said women who who aren't living
their best lives that's everybody that's
every woman that's every man too by the
way you know
stepping in their potential whatever so
it's very it's very broad which which is
the long-term Mission but then inside of
that who do you love helping the most
and whether it relates to food or not
that's the discussion to start to figure
out it's like hey we can we can start to
build this Niche and then expand from
there but inside of that like who do you
love love love helping the most like do
you love helping teenage girls get over
a crush that broke their heart on Prom
Night do you love helping
you know a woman who might have lost her
mom yesterday to cancer you know like
there's so many issues that we will face
and so it's great to Target women but
then what are they struggling with the
most that you love helping them through
and then that becomes
most of the content that you start with
so you can start building your tribe
around it yeah yeah yeah yeah
well it is women that are caught in in
struggling with weight thinking they
need a diet that's going to fix them
because it's really an inside job right
and so I get great set like for instance
I've been working with a new client
recently and after a couple of weeks
she's come to the realization that it's
really not about her weight her
unhappiness and her and that gives me
great gratification and satisfaction yes
she wants to still
be healthy and treat her body with
respect but giving up the struggle and
learning to trust herself more is
that that's what gives me great
gratification that she's she's really
feeling more of um
taking caring enough about herself that
she is willing to have healthier
boundaries with her husband and rather
than focusing on the body image and all
of that getting beyond that is that is
that clear yeah yeah I think that's
great like behind every for all
everybody here you want to have an
impact and we all have a message to to
serve other people
these strategies alone are not going to
be enough
like just telling somebody here's what
you do here's the foods to eat if I
could just tell somebody hey make these
videos go that's not enough because
there's there's emotional resistances to
everything
so you could tell somebody to eat this
food but there's a reason why they're
abusing the food in the first place all
of us have blocks that prevent us from
doing the next thing and so
understanding that really helps so
woman you're helping they're they're
stressed out or they have anxiety they
have body issues and some of them the
ones who you'll like helping the most
they solve they they feed their anxiety
and stress with food
others might do it through drugs others
might do nothing or relationships or
they cut themselves or they you know
like and so that's where like well do
you want to help those women too if
somebody's saying like I've tried to
kill myself four times because I hate my
body and like maybe maybe you don't turn
that person away you know but it's not
like the core of what you want to deal
with because it's not the same path that
you went through right so if women great
awesome plus anxiety stress
self-confidence issue is great that's
going to be everybody but how do they
fix though how are they getting their
fix off is through food
yeah and so you're still addressing the
underlying thing but also helping them
solve the connection to getting their
fix with food right so it's like food
but you're not just gonna teach diet
plans no you're going to teach them
techniques underneath
really of course and but it's not just
that those techniques only work through
food
it could also apply to people who are
cutting themselves or oh yes or for men
too who are doing these it's just not as
much
of a connection to you because you
haven't gone through those things yeah
well I've gone through other addictive
behaviors and and and on because really
my understanding you know if you if you
just transfer one addiction to another
the expression is you're changing seats
on the Titanic I mean you're not
addressing the underlying you're still
going down right and what years ago when
I worked in an eating disorder unit by
the time people got there they had gone
through drug addiction and and gambling
addiction and so all of that stuff is
relevant and yes though as I work with
people for instance I'll work with
somebody who's a food issue and then all
of a sudden after a couple weeks they
feel safe enough with me to real to to
reveal that they drink a bottle of wine
every night and so as we uncover
the core reasons so it's you know on the
onset I I'm I tracked people and
sometimes people don't know oh well I
guess it has more to do with Rapport and
intimacy and Trust as they get to know
me and they feel safe with me then they
reveal more
about who they are and also knowing if
you've been through the thing that
they're going through because you can
make the connection between addictive
behaviors but other people may not right
so like have you ever lost your home
because of a gambling problem
well my father was a compulsive gambling
Gambler and we lost many homes
but so that's that speaks to like family
so my family member is doing this but
have you ever done it
have I lost a home I haven't lost a home
but I've
lost a lot I don't have a gambling issue
great so but I have an issue with
supporting men because that came out of
that Dynamic that my mother I've had in
my history I don't do that today but in
my history I've supported men and given
them a lot of money
great I'm a little ashamed of even
saying that but it was because of the
Dynamics of the gambling you know so
that was well listen you're in a safe
space and thank you for having the
courage to share that with us if you
haven't told other people before but
these are things that you can speak to
right it's not that if somebody has
their own gambling problem
um you won't help them but it's just not
it's not you you you didn't go and lose
your home but if somebody came and said
my father has again or my mother or
somebody my family has a gambling
addiction or I keep supporting people
for some reason why do I keep supporting
these men who have gambling problems
what is wrong with me like somebody that
person you would love helping so much
more than I have a gambling problem
because it's more through your
experience of what you've lived like if
somebody came to you and said I keep
supporting men who have gambling
problems what's wrong with me and then
you help them realize there's nothing
wrong with you
right and you teach them to actually
love herself and just get out of these
negative relationships that's going to
make you feel amazing yes so it's and I
hope I mean we're spending a lot of time
on this but hopefully everybody can see
that kind of similar Journey for your
own self the thing that you have been
through where you felt hopeless
worthless like when your dad did that
and you lost your home or you gave money
and
just how terrible like it made you feel
terrible about yourself and if you then
subsidized through food like okay well
I'm just gonna go eat that pizza or
Doritos or whatever just to make me feel
good because I don't have any happiness
in my life anywhere right like this is
where people get really stuck so that's
your Niche you know the people who are
currently struggling with a thing that
you struggled through and it doesn't
mean we ignore everybody else we can't
help them and we're going to turn them
away but it's not who we're actively
trying to go out and serve because if
you just go out and say ladies have more
self-confidence it becomes too broad a
message
but then you end up we end up trying to
serve everybody and ends up serving very
few people
does that help yes it's very helpful I
had the modalities that I do use is
tapping and I really love the
conversation you had with Melanie
because it's not all the only thing I
use and but a lot of my YouTube videos
have been focused on that because
there's a whole niche of people that are
but I use the tapping specific to that
weight body image and so so like who I
how right that from Bill to serve that's
the how the how the how matters less
about what the how is and matters more
that you believe in the how like if if
somebody sees you and say I'm in the
same situations Maria I've been over
eating to combat my stress because of
whatever happened in my life and you're
gonna say I'm exactly like you here's
how I got through it tapping great show
me how to do it like the how does it
matter
what matters is that it actually worked
for you yeah and that because I love you
and I connect to your story I'm gonna
now have more belief in the strategy
that you're gonna give me on how to get
out as well so if tapping helped you
then incorporate into your content yes
if it helped you for everything great
put it everywhere if it helped you only
for specific problems you should make it
for those specific problems but bringing
it into your content bring it into your
coaching whatever got you out of the
hole
is the thing then you teach other people
because that's your job is to get them
out of the hole that they're in as well
and we all have we all have different
house right and you don't have to use
the same have for every situation but
how did you get out of the situation you
were in and now we teach that yeah we're
thought leaders
I love it it just reminds me of somebody
booked a consult with me tomorrow and
when I when somebody books I ask them to
just put anything that they have to say
and she said she said I'm not sure about
tapping but I'm sure about you she's
been following me for a while yeah and
um it really just spoke to what you were
saying she felt comfortable enough to
have the consult with me to potentially
work with me but she wasn't sure about
tapping yeah like the how doesn't matter
this is why in movement makers for this
challenge that we're doing when when I'm
rejecting everybody putting in their
like their four steps to do things or
the three ways or the age like the
strategies do not matter
what matters is the connection to you I
don't given me eight strategies is not
the benefit
what's the specific the specific benefit
that I'm gonna get from working with you
and so that's the whole game if you get
them to to know you like you trust you
which comes from you telling your story
if I start talking about women's weight
issues
you're not a woman you don't know me you
don't know what I'm going through right
like it's going to be the first like who
even if I have all the same strategies
they're not gonna listen to me because
I'm not a woman
right and and that's an obvious like
hopefully you can tell that I'm not a
woman
like that's a pretty obvious thing but
the thing is a lot of these things that
we
have struggled with are not obvious like
knowing that you struggled if I look at
you I don't think you struggle with food
if I look at you I don't think you had
men in your life who had gambling issues
that you supported so when you come out
and say Here's how you solve it it
doesn't come across like who is this
woman who's preaching to me
right you're not and this is hopefully
applicable to everybody like you're not
coming down from your high horse and
preaching people and telling people what
to do you're saying I'm just like you I
was I was in the same spot and I
struggled with this and here's how I
overcame but until you share that story
and I know that you've been through it
and you're at you're like me then then
I'm not gonna listen to you so anyway
most things are not obvious right men
women obvious you know ethnic background
whatever scar on your face like super
obvious but most of the things we deal
with is not obvious and so we need to
share those things and have the courage
and you honestly did it right here it's
like I'm a little embarrassed to say
this it's great
and sharing that will only connect more
people to you like nobody if any people
only feel more love for you in saying
that you struggled with supporting men
who had gambling addictions not oh I'm
not going to talk to Maria now because
of that so thank you for having the
courage to uh to share up thank you Evan
thank you for all that you do thank you
the poll question was from Michael who
said owning your time in schedule so
my quick take on this and then we'll get
to you know questions from you guys
whatever I can help answer in this
little mini break for us today
um I love energy zones I think I think
staying in the same energy Zone really
really really matters so today is
Thursday uh all of my public facing
stuff is on a Thursday I had I start
with movement makers which always gets
me I'm an introvert right so I don't
wake up and like hey Michael Jordan just
in time we're doing your question right
now Michael drive safe though drive safe
um we uh you know I get so much love
from Movie Makers that that gets me
fired up for the rest of the day and so
all I have to do on a Thursday is do my
public facing stuff so all day long it's
just interviews and and sessions like
this and podcasts and Movie Makers and
then three podcasts and then this and
then like four more podcasts and then
live streaming tonight but I'm not
worried about my YouTube channel I'm not
worried about my team I'm not worried
about anything else besides just
spreading the message today and I think
it's great to stay in that energy Zone
because the energy I got from Movie
Makers I'm still pouring into the next
group and the love I get from you guys
I'm pointing to my podcast right after
this and so I don't have to switch I
think switching between different tasks
ends up being really really it's
challenging for everybody maybe extra
challenging for me
um because I think to spend half an hour
on a podcast and then 20 minutes writing
the book and then 40 minutes doing
something else you end up just getting
nothing done you feel like if you ever
felt like I worked all day but I got
nothing done
it's probably because you're switching
between energy states too much and so
all I have to worry about today is this
one thing of spreading the message
um
yesterday was my project day
so this this is a change that I made in
the past year or year and a half that
really made a huge impact was adding
project day in the middle so Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Tuesday is my YouTube
day it's crazy it's crazy it's just I
gotta make videos for 12 different
channels plus two strategy plus it's
just all day long if you're on my team
don't try to reach me on a Tuesday it's
not going to happen I'm just making
videos
Thursdays today is crazy crazy just all
day long interviews and podcasts and
Skypes and just all day long
so in the middle Wednesday is open day
Wednesday is my project day Wednesday I
wake up I'm like what do I want to work
on today
um it doesn't turn into like let's play
League of Legends all day like I like
working but I get to basically pick
whatever project I want to work on and I
like having a freedom
in the middle of the week between the
two crazy days it used to be like write
my book day right you know if I'm right
in the book I need a whole day it's hard
to write a book in 20 minutes a day
because it takes you 20 minutes just to
get back into what you were doing any
kind of creative work if you're doing
creative work you need like chunks of
time without the stress of I need to be
done by one o'clock so it can go off and
do this thing that kills your creativity
so Wednesday's creative work day
um and I've just found I get way way way
way way way more stuff done working the
same number of hours but just way more
productive because I'm not shifting my
energy too much now you may not be in
complete control of your day you might
have a job you might have customers you
might have other responsibilities family
whatever so whatever is inside your
calendar that you can control just being
more intentional with it
and making sure that what's in your
calendar is going to help you get your
goals right like if you want to have a
YouTube channel I was talking about just
before this was on a podcast with the
guys like help me build my YouTube
channel okay great well show me where in
your calendar have you dedicated time to
make YouTube videos
oh I haven't done that well that's why
you're not making YouTube videos dude
it doesn't ever happen it's like yeah
that's why I haven't made a video in the
past three months okay great so it's
it's we can change that we can add that
we can put it in
um but your actions have to be you know
map to your Ambitions what's in your
calendar has to be the thing that you're
working towards every day so I like
different days for different things I
have my morning routine which I do every
day and then I fall into whatever that
day is going to be so mentoring day
Monday YouTube day Tuesday uh
Wednesday's open project Day creative
day Thursdays public facing day
interviews Friday is CEO day grow the
business Saturday is fun day
and then Sunday's family at midday and
even that's an important distinction
Sunday is
go grocery shopping do the laundry
uh
uh whatever I mean whatever has to get
done clean up the condo
you know all the all the stuff that you
have to do to live life that is not fun
but that's kind of required be honest on
a Sunday but it's not on Saturday
I'm not folding laundry on a Saturday
is the only day where we don't even do I
don't even do the dishes you normally my
wife cooks and I do the dishes after not
Saturday Saturday
I'll leave the dishes for Sunday
like Saturday is fun day and it's
important I think to put up the the
blocks on your calendar to more than not
just like what you are going to do but
what you're not going to do
I'm not going to
get interrupted by my team today I am
not going to work on my YouTube channel
today I am not going to and I think that
that really helps you stay a lot more
focused
and then my last is quick thought and
then we can open up if you want me to go
in deeper and Michael know you're here
so if you got questions on that there's
just kind of top level but it also lets
you miss the work I like to miss the
work
like you guys we see each other once a
week now it's like I miss you guys in
between
yeah it's like we get this and then
tomorrow I'm not missing you but then
come like Tuesday Wednesday like when we
get the reader's group and then Thursday
comes you're like Hey we're back
so if you only do something once a week
you're always missing it when it comes
up
so I haven't made YouTube videos since
Tuesday I'm not missing it yet but come
like Friday Saturday it's like oh I want
to make I want to make some YouTube
videos so whatever day I'm about to jump
into I'm always missing the work as
opposed to kind of getting bored
overwhelmed or whatever from it
um so that's really helped me and again
you may not be able to control your
whole day
but whatever you can control just being
intentional with it and asking yourself
hey over the next week I've got seven
days and inside inside of that I've got
14 hours that I can play with I'm gonna
use those 14 hours
that are my time to be able to move
closer to achieving the goals I've got
for myself
that's my quick my quick take Michael to
help you guys got extra questions you
want to dive deeper on it I got another
question
can I ask yeah yeah Michael then we'll
go to we'll go to Nile that's how his
hand up too what do you got okay uh uh
so at the end of the day do you have a
time that you stop with your work and
then that's your family time time to
spend with your kid uh or with the wife
or are you like until you go to bed uh
like you're on making videos until 8 p.m
and then you do your bedtime routine and
go to bed so if I look at a normal
breakdown
um with kind of family time so we'll
I'll go for a walk with my wife in the
morning so I'll take the dogs out then
we'll go for a walk and we spend the
first 45 minutes to an hour of the day
kind of just setting up for the day
we're both not morning people so at the
beginning we're not really talking
it's kind of like holding hands and
walking outside
uh and then as like the Sun hits you and
the fresh air we start
having a conversation hey how's what's
up for today how'd you sleep last night
and just kind of I like walking the day
with some fresh air and not just being
inside all the time
um especially now with everything going
on it's like we don't get enough
outside stuff that we get to do
um then usually we'll take a break at 2
30.
uh we both have that in our calendar it
was a break for half an hour 2 30 to
connect it could be
um
depending on how we're feeling it could
be another like quick outside just take
the dogs to the park super quick come
back up but that kind of built into our
schedule
um
after that I'll go back to work uh
usually until at least five five to six
is like my buffer zone for anything
urgent
so
you know today is my interview day I
actually have a gap from five to six but
I put that in because we booked so far
in advance for guests for my me to be on
shows that if something really urgent
comes up I hate having to post postpone
somebody or cancel on somebody like
worst case we can but if some big
opportunity comes up we have that as our
buffer zone just kind of like hotels off
in the the penthouse suite is open just
in case some big person comes in there's
there's a room for them they have to
kick somebody out
um six to seven thirty ish I'm doing my
live stream usually four days a week
with Zan here and and Drew and then from
7 30 to what nine
uh it's usually playing with the kids
uh right now we're doing a lot of
Minecraft together uh because three
different cities you know nieces and
nephews all that stuff we just join on a
Minecraft server together I'm not very
good at Minecraft
um but whatever it's a fun thing to do
and I think there's a lot of actual life
lessons that happen like if you go and
you build your character in Minecraft
and then you step into lava and you lose
all your stuff do you rage quit and
freak out or can you talk that through
right and like I think you can parent
and teach and life lessons through
everything and the more you're doing
things that they like as opposed to like
forcing to do what you want
um there's actually better teaching
there
nine to ten Nina and I usually watch a
show right now we're watching Homeland
uh we're on the last season of Homeland
working our way through usually we're
watching like some of the superhero
movies or shows uh
Legends of tomorrow and what else we
watch Green Arrow
uh anyway there was this big gap of no
shows coming out it's like oh we got
nothing to watch so we fell into home
line and that's pretty good
um but that's one hour
then I wash the dishes take the dogs out
um answer the questions I do like 10
questions with Evan and then we get
ready for bed
um
so that's a typical like Monday to
Friday kind of day Friday night would
probably just stay up a little bit later
and do stuff together but that's a
typical weekday so uh there's a morning
time there's an afternoon time when
there's an evening time
um spread out between like just the two
of us or time with family too so far
works but it's constant like Minor
Adjustments as we go Nile what'd you got
hey can you hear me today yeah we got
you yeah excellent yes hey your wall is
basically the same as mine dude it's
just it's it's orange I don't I I mine's
orange I know yours is coming through
with red I love you yours kind of looks
red just a little lighter but I like it
dude this is great thanks and listen I
have been I haven't had a chance to
speak this is fantastic of what you're
doing here and um I think this is great
and everything that people share is
fantastic you mind if I take it off
topics just for a little bit from the
scheduling or do you want to focus you
know whatever whatever you guys want one
quick question I had was what would you
suggest or what's your thought on
building a brand on you as a person
compared to building a brand around an
entity or a company name or a theme
person's always easier okay your story
is your greatest Advantage right why is
somebody going to buy from you versus
some giant Corporation because they feel
like you actually care about them
but where you lose is you don't have the
history you don't have the reputation
you don't have the name brand yet you
think about whoever the biggest
competitors are in your industry like
why it's the old expressive nobody got
fired for buying IBM
um like the big brands that they're
trusted so they may not treat you super
well but at least you know what you're
getting and they have a history and
they're likely not going to screw you
over
um so if you're if you're a logo
you're basically taking the worst of
Both Worlds where if you make it your
personal brand they may not they may not
know you yet but it's like man this guy
cares
that's why sharing your story right I
mean
why emphasize so much in here is sharing
your story matters is what makes people
connect to you that okay maybe you don't
have the history of the reputation yet
but man I feel like this guy actually
cares about me and I wanna I wanna
I want to do business with him
sorry out of the theme itself uh Builds
on and stems from my story and how I
could further serve that's that's where
I'm thinking of going I've just
reincarnated myself but I rebranded
myself but it wasn't it's not me
necessarily it's me I'm all that's on on
my branding but it's backed by a mantra
and that that has to tie to your your
purpose of course yeah that's why you
tell your story because that's who
you're trying to help in reading your
story I need to feel like oh my God this
guy gets me right this guy is exactly
who I am and I need I need his help like
you're you're a hundred steps ahead but
you're the same person and so I can
learn from you because
you get me that's your biggest Advantage
your story is your biggest Advantage as
an entrepreneur right right I just
didn't know if it would be possession
from hey Nile it's me or the concept of
my brand not the concept but the
positioning of my brain so it it opens
up something that becomes familiar
um very similar to your your one word
that's that's word yeah like you are
your brand right right so it's not this
isn't this is what happened with your
one word and then build the service
believe isn't just a strategy for me
I am believe it's my who same thing for
all you guys like when you figure out
your who it's who you are and you show
up
everywhere as that so I I right now I'm
believing in you guys and I'm believing
all the people that I'm doing shows with
afterwards but when I when I come home
and still believe it's still spreading
belief to my wife and my family it's it
takes on a different life right I'm not
telling Nina go make your YouTube
content and spread your message but it's
still you know believing in her so it's
not just a hat that you wear it's
actually who you are so Nile equals
blank not just oh this is my business
stands for this but I stand for
something different
right perfect thank you
varindra yeah yeah and that's right
Yvonne thank you thank you thank you for
having these sessions uh wonderful to
have you thanks a lot first of all and
uh hi everyone my question is on this
point you just mentioned about the one
word so I got your one word book now so
reading through it but if you can kind
of help in terms of how we find it and
will be
uh you know get that through quickly so
we can start more
did you go through the five questions
of like your favorite teacher I I have
just started reading you yesterday of me
so I have got to that point the chapter
two where the five questions are there
so I'll be going to answer them okay so
that that honestly that's the best thing
like go through the questions the both
books were not designed as just uh
read the book and put it away it's like
it's it's a you have to think you have
to do the exercises you know it's a it's
almost a workbook inside a book
um if you want to get the value out of
it I think the best thing is go through
the questions and if you get stuck
come back next week and and we'll
Workshop it
okay yeah fine thank you
I saw a lady had her hand up lady Alexey
I'm trying to figure out how to work my
schedule uh as in uh recording videos
and all the other stuff ever since I've
been dealing with the death of my mom
and my kids and I'm swamped by
whether it's an appointment with the
attorney cleaning up the house
um you name it real estate agents of
course my brother my sister but you know
I have limited amount of energy I have
to juggle through it all so you were
talking about your schedule during the
day and I'm like okay how would I be
able to maintain some sort of schedule
uh along with the regular clients I've
got and and trying to get my story
online that's actually why I didn't
record because I was so tired at night
so you know there are moments where you
need to give yourself more grace right
and and you know sorry to hear about
your mom and your cat and
um you know we lost our family dog uh
not too long ago and
uh some people you know see that as
mushy or whatever but it's a big deal
like it's part of your family
um we also lost uh my sister-in-law last
year at the end of the year
um like 40 years old got to some super
rare cancer three kids
um one teen and two pre-teens and that
uh
that took us all out
you know I was not being nearly as
productive as I could have been
um
uh I wasn't doing as many shows as I
usually had my Wednesday or Friday might
have been completely gone instead of
doing creative work I'm spending the
time with my nieces or nephews just
not even doing much is being with them
because their mom just died and what do
you do as an eight-year-old right just
to have some kind of
love their um they're still you know
they were trying to figure out school
they're no school and just dealing with
it
um so this Grace you know there are some
moments in life where you have to give
yourself a little bit more grace and
understand that you're not going to be
at your regular capacity when I broke my
neck you know
that was brutal
but I still made videos every day you
know I think like having something that
you can hang your hat on to
to even if you're even if you're tired
even if you're not 100 just to look back
and say like I'm still not giving up on
my ambitions
so whatever that looks like for you like
if making videos is really important to
you I would still make videos and post
like you can make a five minute video I
made a video from my hospital bed with
my broken neck and a concussion
and
Doug Wilder is not here in the house
right now but he took a screenshot of it
and it looks like I'm dead
I mean it's probably just a bad
screenshot too but I've got my neck
brace on like this giant scab across my
forehead and it was definitely not
anywhere close to being my best content
but I'm you know looking back super
proud that I still did it
to do the difficult thing when it's hard
it was my best content it was a five
minute video instead of I committed to
going live every day right while I was
on my tour and everybody
yeah
so it's it's okay to to let go of the
structure you know with opinion and all
that stuff and just post like one minute
videos and you know without the
beginning and the ends you know the
bumper and food are
let go of all that
at the end of the day
all that matters is how proud are you of
yourself
are you proud that you did the best that
you could give him what you had
so if you're gonna say hey I can either
not make a video because it's not
perfect or I can make a one minute video
with everything else going on but it
won't have the structure
I'd rather you make the one minute video
I I did record them I just didn't post
them uh yeah and I did write notes so I
would like to go in it you know after
all
posts and then recognize now if it's a
year later and you're still
here that's a problem right so like
there's a grace period and grief is real
right but if it's three years later and
you're still in grief and you still
can't do anything then that's that's a
bigger problem that we need to to work
through but for the most part I think of
all the negative emotions
you know if you think positive emotions
like courage and ambition and drive and
service and all that and negative
emotions of of fear and anger and
jealousy and all of that
every negative emotion I want to try to
eliminate from my life except for grief
grief is a special one
like I don't want to have jealousy in my
life I don't want to have anger or or
um any of the like strong negative
emotions but grief not that I want grief
in my life but it's it it just has to be
worked through
like if I'm jealous about somebody I
don't want to work I want to fix it and
get rid of it I don't want to be jealous
of other people but grief you can't just
get rid of it like if you dive into your
work
it's still there
you know you can't just forget about it
and so you have to work through it and
time will heal and you won't be as
productive as you could be normally
would be and that's fine there's a
little bit of Grace I think all of us
and if you haven't had any grief yet
it's it's going to happen at some point
I mean it's just the Human Experience oh
I I did I did have it and of course I
still go to to start to be like two
times a week for my ankles so you know
it's juggling with limited amount of
energy but I I also noticed that I
really want to continue on with the
business the drive is there
so release make your one minute videos
and release it
okay thank you
if you want to get a copy of Bill to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there I'll see you there
I'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love